ocean master and Aquaman in terms of
siblings the older one really got the
shaft on the name right I'm Aquaman
here's my brother ocean master you're
right I'll just go I'll sit over here
you two have fun
poor Arthur these are the things I think
about
[Music]
Aquaman so Aquaman is a DC movie
starring Jason Momoa as Arthur curry who
is Aquaman his father's a lighthouse
keeper his mother was Atlanta and
royalty so they had the kid Arthur who
was a person of both worlds buddy has
his brother or who rules Atlantis so he
has to go challenge him for the throne
and you know how that goes I thought
Jason Momoa was really good as Arthur
curry until now I haven't gotten a good
look as to how he was gonna be portrayed
in his moving some shots from the
trailers sure they're still played up
though those bad as we're falling out of
a plane I'm like is he like bode from
Point Break buddy then I said that in
chain of thought Point Break reference
made me think of Tony Stark and his
Point Break reference he made in the
Avengers which made me think of the fact
that Arthur curry makes movie references
like that in here never says she's gonna
fight someone he's like hey Fight Club
hold on I was like are you Tony Stark in
right now like Tony Stark is the only
one with the license to do that I'm just
saying you know when they were making
this movie they were like it totally
works for Tony Stark 7 do that but if it
works it works it made me chuckle but I
like Jason Momoa betrayal who's Arthur
curry he's up here dude he's just a
simple guy he's a simple guy who doesn't
want to be king nor is he probably
qualified to be king but he's a good
dude with a pure heart so dammit he's
qualified here but I don't know there's
logistics and politics of your world
doesn't matter fight your brother for
the throne dude we did see him in
Justice League we got to feel for him
there sure but you got the feeling that
were probably gonna be some retcons like
they were gonna go about Aquaman a
little differently since they kind of
changed up the DC EU and what they
wanted to do the direction they were
going versus the direction they're now
going and I think there are some
differences changes some retcon you see
that scene in Justice League where
Arthur curries talking to Mara
completely different character Mara is
completely different Arthur and that
seems like my mom gave me up didn't even
give me a second thought you kind of get
the feeling he has like a chip on his
shoulder for that he does not be his mom
in that light at all in this movie much
longer story that I wanted to make it
short I liked Jason Momoa as Arthur Kerr
I like Amber Heard as Mara - I would
have liked Mara to have a little bit of
edge to her I mean Mara is like I don't
like the surface world they're all dicks
I remember this one scene in the comic
book not saying this totally has to
follow the comic book completely but it
was a really cool scene where someone's
giving her [ __ ] and she can control
water and she starts evaporating the
water from the person's body she doesn't
kill him she just wants him to know -
shut up there's no moment like that in
here for her it's kind of like I don't
like the surface world but let's pal
around I'll help you her character is
completely likable in fact when you
watch the Justice League scene after
Aquaman which a totally YouTube because
I had questions like did he know her
before that same because I kind of got
the feeling he did when I watched
Justice League when you watch this movie
it's like that's the first time they
meet I kind of watch it with new eyes
but by comparison her role in Justice
League she comes across as completely
boring Aquaman much more interesting so
I'll take this I just wish they would
have played up a bit more of her
character on hey I don't like the
surface people they play it fine I just
wish they would have played it up a bit
more maybe give her a Cobra Kai kind of
moment where it's like who don't act
like that just do it in self-defense
maybe I also really liked the action the
action was really excited in terms of
the early trailers - now they have
changed up the voices I remember first
when I saw the trailer I was like it
doesn't even look like they're
underwater it doesn't seem like they're
underwater doesn't sound like they're
underwater it's a little weird it's
freaking my brain out they do alter
their voices slightly there are more
bubbles underwater as makes it feel like
they're more underwater so I'm glad I
did that but back to the point the
action the fights top notch there's a
small throwdown in a room near the
beginning and I was like oh that's how
the action is gonna be because that was
really cool just totally like that when
the fights and throwdowns are going down
you are engaged you can't take your eyes
off of it it was solid comic-book movie
action also Black Manta was really cool
when he was here when he was on-screen
he was great they do some good setup for
him then he's there for one fight and
then after that he's not there anymore
and they kind of bummed me out he's like
Boba Fett but he did a bit more I just
think you can revolve a whole movie
around Black Manta story black mantas
story lends itself to you possibly
feeling bad for Black Manta it makes you
feel a bit conflicted but really don't
ever because he's a dick from the start
and he totally gets eclipsed and
overshadowed by the plot at hand it's
like you must fight your brother for the
throne for the sake of the world and oh
yeah that guy kind of has a grudge fight
him once just a bit dwarfed by the
situation and it brings me to a point
this movie is really entertaining a lot
of fun but it's also a lot just period
it's just a lot a lot happens in this
movie you know how a lot of people are
like oh this movie was kind of like this
movie meets that movie usually they
compare two movies to describe one movie
this is like dune meets black panther or
Lion King which ever meets Uncharted
yeah it's in here it sounds weird but
that's a part of it like they had a few
different ideas for an Aquaman movie
they were like let's crush them all
together and make an Aquaman movie
because in the end I enjoyed Aquaman
it's about two hours twenty minutes I
liked Arthur curry I liked his brother
arm I liked the conflict between the two
maybe they should have saved that
conflict for the second movie and had
the first movie be Black Manta
I wish Black Manta had had a larger role
in this movie storytelling wise none of
it's as good or smooth as Geoff Johns
Aquaman run
I always talk about it when talked about
Aquaman but it's really good but the
most important thing happened and that
is I got what I'm looking for when I go
to the movies and that is I enjoyed
myself at the movies I will say Aquaman
is a good time no alcohol required and
something I really like and respect his
movie for is the fact that this Aquaman
movie is an Aquaman movie what I mean by
that is it's not a Justice League sequel
it's not a Justice League two prequel it
doesn't use this Aquaman movie to set up
whatever's coming next in the DCU
if it even exists I've heard conflicting
stories Aquaman isn't a birds-of-prey
setup movie it keeps it in the pocket
it's Aquaman's story Arthur curry story
what's happening in his world his life
the world of Atlantis he has to
reluctantly take on his brother to
hopefully take on the throne to save the
world cool that's Aquaman's story it
doesn't rely on anything that came
before it it doesn't use this - first
and foremost set up whatever's coming
next
I saw Aquaman have you seen it what did
you think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]